welcome to top10archive savant syndrome
is defined as a condition in which a
person demonstrates capacities or
abilities that are greatly in excess to
that of which would be considered normal
people with savant syndrome may have
neurodevelopmental disorders notably
autism spectrum disorders or brain
injuries for this installment we're
counting down ten extraordinary savants
that are capable of mind-blowing things
number ten Jonathan Lerman Jonathan
Lerman is an autistic savant with an IQ
of just 53 at just two years old
Lerman would begin to slide into long
silences and would be diagnosed autistic
just a year later while his autism made
it difficult for him to communicate in a
typical manner his artistic ability
would help him express what he was
thinking by the age of 10 he began
drawing charcoal portraits of friends
and people he had seen even if he had
just made them up in his mind at the age
of 14
Lerman had his pieces appearing in new
york art galleries number 9 Stephen
Wiltshire diagnosed with autism at a
young age Stephen Wiltshire was sent to
a school for special needs children
there his passions were encouraged and
he would find a love of drawing mute
since a very young age Stephen would use
his art to communicate since childhood
not learning to speak until he was nine
he began drawing highly detailed and
incredibly accurate portraits of things
that he saw
Stephens talent however goes much
further than just that in 2009 he was
flown over Tokyo for a mere 20 minutes
and upon his return to land was able to
draw a 10 meter or nearly 33 foot long
picture of the city number 8 Daniel
Tammet facing terrible epileptic
seizures as well as diagnosis of autism
at the age of four
Daniel developed the ability to
visualize and calculate numbers in his
head Daniel Tammet can calculate numbers
on a massive scale once reciting PI from
memory to the 22,500 14th decimal a feat
he accomplished on Pi Day to raise funds
for the National Society for epilepsy
as well as his amazing mathematical
talent Tamid is capable of learning
languages at an unprecedented rate
learning Icelandic in just seven days
Daniel's form of autism is incredibly
uncommon even among other savants as he
is able to articulate his thoughts
clearly number seven
Kim peak if you've ever heard of the
movie Rain Man then you've heard the
story of Kim peak though you probably
didn't know it born with severe brain
damage
Kim's childhood doctors suggest that his
father sent him to an institution and
forget about him as his developmental
disabilities were thought to keep him
from walking let alone anything else
Kim's father didn't agree and returned
home with his son he does have problems
walking and learning is difficult for
him however he has the ability to read
books to pages at once in roughly three
seconds not just that but he remembers
everything he reads in them number six
Leslie Lemke in an unfortunate twist of
fate Leslie Lemke was born with severe
birth defects ones that required the
removal of his eyes his birth mother
gave him up for adoption and it was at
that point that one May Lemke took him
in as one of her own at just six months
of age at age 16 Leslie displayed his
hidden talent when Mae woke up in the
middle of the night to find Leslie
playing Tchaikovsky's piano concerto
number one Leslie had no musical
training but still managed to play
flawlessly after just hearing the song
one time Leslie now plays all kinds of
music and just like he did with the
Tchaikovsky piece he needs only to hear
it once number five
Toni de Blois born premature and
underweight Toni de Blois was hardly
breathing the doctors rushed to place an
oxygen mask on him unbeknownst to them
at the time that too much oxygen causes
blindness couple blindness with slow
physical development then add in autism
and you have the challenges that Tony de
Blois faces every day at age 2 Toni sat
down in front of a piano for the first
time growing into music
he learned to play over 20 different
instruments including guitar trumpet and
the ukulele
it's estimated that Tony has roughly
8,000 musical pieces memorized which he
learned all by ear
number four Jason Padgett though most
people with savant syndrome are born
with it
others can acquire it through severe
trauma and brain injury such as the case
of Jason Padgett after being brutally
beaten during a mugging Jason awoke the
next day in the hospital though
something was different he now sees the
world overlaid in complex mathematical
formulas over time he would begin to
transcribe what he saw through drawings
these drawings took the form of
intricate fractal form shapes and
patterns when neurologists took scans of
his brain what they found was his brain
activated rarely-used portions to
compensate for the damaged areas number
3 Orlando Serrell Orlando Serrell was
not born autistic or brain damaged but
rather known as an acquired savant one
day Sorrell was playing baseball with
some friends at age 10 Sorrell was
struck in the left side of the head by a
ball but was able to finish the game
figuring he was okay once his headache
cleared he never thought to seek medical
attention Sorrell came to find he
developed a talent called calendar
calculating meaning he could tell you
what day of the week any date fell on
even more amazing he can tell you what
the weather was like on that day where
he was number two
Alonzo Clements due to a head injury he
suffered when he was just a child
Alonzo Clemens lost much but in return
gained a beautiful and magnificent
talent determined by doctors to have an
IQ of no higher than 40 Clemens was left
to be seemingly emotionless though his
face would light up with joy with clay
in his hands you see Clemens gained a
gift of art when he looks at an animal
he's able to create a sculpture a very
fine detail using only his hands
his sense of touch is so accurate that
he's even able to make these sculptures
in the dark
number one flow and K Lyman Florence and
Catherine Lyman also known as the
Rainman twins are said to be the only
female autistic savant twins in the
world even more impressive is the fact
that they are the only pair of savant
twins with the same talents they have
the ability of calendar calculation and
can tell you what the weather was like
what a TV personality was wearing and
what they ate for nearly every day of
their lives
the twins even went as far as to
document what color clothing their
favorite TV host war including Dick
Clark from the $100,000 pyramid hey
everyone thanks for watching if you'd
like to see more videos like this be
sure to visit and sign up with our
friends at geek fuel by using our
affiliate link found in the description
section for just twenty dollars a month
you'll receive at least $50 worth of
geeky stuff that you'll actually use
each box comes with a t-shirt you'll
actually want to wear and a free steam
game download usually valued at $10 or
more don't miss out on this monthly box
that Stanley himself endorses be sure to
subscribe to our channel to keep updated
or more lists like these box openings
and giveaways you know the savants are
really amazing I can't even remember in
the mornings where I put my shoes
you